we know what that what this uh what this
game means to our fan base and um just
really really special wish they could
have been in the building honestly to uh
to experience it it would have been
it would have been crazy i'm sure and uh
hopefully everyone at home enjoy it this
is an emotional win for for our entire
city um
a lot's going into this to get us to
where we are and there's still a lot of
football yet to be played a lot of
things we have to get better at but
i'm gonna go home tonight and just uh
take an hour to just enjoy being around
my family here
[Music]
sean mcdermott bill's head coach after
toppling the new england patriots
is it time to sing ding dong the witch
is dead we're getting close i mean we
should start like warming up the band
and you know warming up our vocals a
little bit because i think it's i mean
it might be right around the corner
i look
they played the bills tougher than most
people thought they would the game could
have gone either way yeah starting to
get that vibe that oh crap the patriots
are actually going to win this game
before cam newton fumbled
in the red zone
with you know just enough time left for
the bills to take a knee or two and end
it so uh i i i don't think the patriots
are as bad no as two and five would
suggest i agreed but they're running out
of chances there's only so many losses
you can take before your path to the
postseason even with seven spots in the
afc
it it's just not gonna happen and and
they've got to go
at two and five through seven games they
gotta go seven and two i think pretty
much have a chance i don't know that's a
team that can go seven and two i i i i i
agree i mean it's gonna be tough i mean
where they're sitting right now yeah
seven and two and i'm not even sure
that'll make it i mean you know you look
at the afc
what oh you're looking at your bingo
things the bingo but you look what that
that was
let me somebody's a little too happy
with the the the bingo trigger finger
that's all right keep it going keep the
bingo thing going it annoys mike you can
see that so do you pull it any time you
want um either way no no it doesn't
annoy me like being slowed down at the
door on the way into the building no it
does a story no it doesn't but nine and
seven i mean i don't know if that's
gonna make it this year in the afc
playoffs i don't to where i look at it
i'm like i'm not sure they they might
only be able to lose one game really and
now they have a somewhat of a favorable
schedule they've gotten a lot of their
tough teams out of the way but they're
still
certainly not like slam dunks not with
the way new england plays i mean you saw
the way they play yesterday every game
is going to look like that for new
england it's not really going to be any
different
they can't win unless they can run and
control the clock and cam's gonna be
able to run they're not good enough in
the past game you know they're worse
this year than they were last year so
you look at what they got on the
schedule
a lot of winnable games there's no doubt
you know they could make a run here they
got baltimore in two weeks that's the
only game on here you can look at and
just go
oh
new england will lose that one all right
but other than that when you talk about
jets texans cardinals chargers rams
dolphins bills jets i understand some of
those teams you could say are better but
i'm not going to slam dunk they're going
to beat the new england patriots and
that's why i'm kind of with you i'm
warming up the vocals but they're not
dead yet
uh but they're in deep trouble now
that's for sure yeah look the if they
lose to the jets then then it oh clearly
good night the the ravens game which
will be on nbc that will be the
opportunity for the patriots to
re-establish their footing and if they
should win that one somehow find a way
to win remember last year it was the
ravens that burst the patriots bubble at
a time where we're thinking
man this may be 2007 all over again and
it's an 85 bears defense and all of that
the ravens change that narrative quickly
if the patriots can return the favor
then then maybe the window opens because
then you're four and five
and every year there's a team
that's around 500
near thanksgiving
that figures it out in december starts
playing those late regular season games
like postseason games and then the next
thing you know they're in 2001 by the
way the patriots were five and five
through ten games and they won the super
bowl let's hear from cam newton and bill
belichick about yesterday's almost
against the buffalo bills
you know i still
am jeopardizing this team's success
because of my lackluster performances of
protecting football so
you know
coach trusts me with the ball in my
hands and i wouldn't want it any other
way and i just got to do a better job
protecting it do you think um you're
gonna go with cam for the rest of the
way or
um do you guys intend to to turn things
over to jared see how
he fares
uh cams are quarterback so it's been all
year
you know he didn't react the way he did
back in 2014 when the question was
raised of jimmy garoppolo playing in
place of tom brady which was to scoff
and make a face and say we're on to
cincinnati so at least at least it's not
as big of a no-brainer as it was then
and for good reason look jay glazer
reported yesterday on the fox pregame
show that the patriots are very
concerned about the mistakes that cam
newton keeps making and there will be
consequences if the mistakes continue
and at a certain point the incredible
talent level
is superseded by carelessness with the
football right and what happened
yesterday look you run the ball the
ball's hanging out there you don't have
it tucked tight against your body you're
not giving maximum grip on it and
there's an opportunity for someone to
come punch it out and that's exactly
what happened yeah that's exactly what
happened you're right i mean he's you
know he's trying to make a play he's
weaving through traffic
you lose you know just that little
disconnect of wait let me keep the ball
really squeezed close to my body really
hard because you're kind of reading
blocks and trying to weave through it
and he got hit just right right at the
right time you know and and yeah the the
turnovers and the mistakes they are
concerning you know he's just yet to
kind of
recreate the mojo he had before he got
covered 19. now yesterday was better he
was better and i think where bill still
you see him make those kind of comments
like no cam's our quarterback because
yes
hey jared sidham you know i know they
like him and they believe in him but i
think they also look at the way their
team is currently constructed and they
realize wait well jared stidham we're
gonna have to get back into the drop
back pass game and like play
tom brady type football with him as the
quarterback and they're no way they're
built like that there's no way they
can't spread the field and start doing
that you know they need the element of
cam newton's running right now to create
some schematic schematical advantages
for their football team and that's why i
think they'll ride with cam until
yes maybe another game or two of really
bad egregious turnovers to where then he
might be in trouble but for now i think
they realize he's he's arguably the most
dangerous weapon they got and they have
to use it as much as they can just to
find ways to move the football
buffalo bills had 190 rushing yards but
gave up 188 now look the bills it's nice
to see they can win on a day when josh
allen doesn't throw for 350 yards right
they're six and two they're two and two
over the last four games though they've
lost some of that spark some of that
magic that we saw earlier in the season
definitely
there's there's there's definitely a gap
between them
and the upper echelon teams in the afc
that they're gonna have to figure out a
way to close right agreed right like i
look at buffalo i use this phrase i
don't know if you tell me if you agree
they're a they're a playoff football
team they're not a super bowl football
team they're not in the super bowl
conversation not for me you know they
might get in the playoffs and win a game
maybe they'll get you know the right
matchup and maybe they win too but i
don't look at them as being a true super
bowl contender there's just too many
issues there first off they're way too
josh allen dependent i mean it's really
it's like you've said they they have to
him and the passing game kind of have to
carry the team you know they're not they
haven't been good running the ball the
defense has not been good
but yesterday was a good gritty ugly win
but yes i'm with you i don't look at
them in the class of pittsburgh kansas
city baltimore seattle you know green
bay tampa bay i don't think they're in
that class of a football team
one i think those two losses they had on
a tuesday night and then a monday night
to the titans and the chiefs that kind
of put the ceiling over the bills and at
a certain level even though you'll hear
all the cliches
they know it they know it you know each
player individually understands you you
you know when there's a category of team
above you yes and you you just can't
flip a switch somewhere and match them
maybe you get lucky maybe
you're gonna show up for the games
you're gonna give it your all but you
know deep down
that yeah there's you'll need a break or
two to win a game you're right you'll
need a break or two if we're gonna play
pittsburgh they're gonna need a break or
two and probably hope yes pittsburgh
does something
stupid along the lines and josh allen
and company will have to do something
crazy good too to win those type of
football games but hey they're they're
going in the right direction again josh
allen's been really good this year we
can't lose sight of that it's been
struggle a little bit the last few weeks
there's no doubt they've played some
good defenses too we can't we can't you
know vrable spag spagnolo for the chiefs
belichick those are three guys that have
great knowledge of their scheme itself
and then hey the jets were crammed in
there too and greg williams and company
you know they're not horrible on that
side of the football but the bills are
going to be in this conversation i mean
i think they're the team to beat in the
afc east i don't know how you feel i i
see miami but i'm not going to throw
that on to tua yet i'd like to see a
little bit more before i say they're
better than the buffalo bills and josh
allen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports